- [Narrator] In this
video, we're going to think
about the concept of
minimum efficient scale
and then how that impacts
market concentration.
And we're going to make sure we understand
what both of these ideas are.
So first of all, minimum efficient scale,
you can view it as the smallest scale
at which we stop getting
economies of scale,
or another way of thinking
about it is the minimum scale
at which we are no longer,
our long-run average total
cost curve is declining.
So in this example, let's see,
when we talk about our taco trucks,
when we were at about 80 units,
we're not at minimum efficient scale yet
because our long-run
average total cost curve
is still declining as we add
more and more and more units.
We're getting economies of
scale all the way until,
at least in this example,
it looks like our long-run
average total cost curve
stops declining around 200 units.
So in this example,
that would be our minimum efficient scale,
which is sometimes abbreviated as MES.
And one way to think about it
is this is the minimum scale
at which an operation needs to run at
in order to be very competitive,
in order to be truly efficient
out there in the market.
Because you can imagine,
if some operators are able
to achieve minimum efficient
scale of, let's say,
getting to the 200 tacos a
day while others are not,
let's say they're only able
to stay at 100 tacos per day,
and if the market were
to get very competitive
and the price of a taco were to go down
to, say, 55 cents per taco,
the people who are at
minimum efficient scale
could still operate and still make money
while the people who are not
at minimum efficient scale,
well, they're not going
to be able to participate
in the market.
And most well-functioning markets,
it gets quite competitive.
And so economists like to think about
what the minimum efficient scale is
and compare that to
the entire market size.
Now, what do we mean by market size?
Well, it depends on how you
are defining the market.
In our example of our taco trucks,
it might be the market for tacos,
market for tacos
in our city.
And of course, you can
define different markets.
You could define it as the market
for food trucks in our city.
You could define it as the
market for tacos in our state
or our country. But let's say if we were
to say the market for tacos in our city,
and let's say that that market is 10,000,
10,000 tacos
per day.
Well, in this reality,
our minimum efficient
scale is 200 tacos per day,
and it's a very small
fraction of the total market.
And so that means that you could have
many different competitors,
each at that minimum efficient scale,
so they're able to produce
tacos at that 50 cents per taco.
And because of that,
you are likely to have many competitors.
So when this,
when our minimum efficient
scale is a small fraction
of the total market, that is
going to lead to fragmentation.
So here, we're going to have a fragmented,
fragmented market.
So if this circle were to
represent the 10,000 tacos
that are sold per day,
if you're able to have
a lot of competitors,
each operating at minimum efficient scale,
in fact, there's no real advantage
to operating above minimum efficient scale
because then you start
getting diseconomies to scale,
well, then you are going to
have maybe 50 competitors
who are splitting this market.
So I won't take the trouble of
making this into 50 different chunks.
So one competitor has
that part of the market.
Another competitor has
And you could imagine we're
going to have this market
fragmented into maybe
50 different players,
and so that's why it's called
a very fragmented market.
But let's say that the
minimum efficient scale
was pretty close to the market size.
So let's say instead of a
market for 10,000 tacos per day,
let's say that the market
in our city is for 400,
400 tacos
per day.
Well, then the market is going
to be smaller, like this.
And so then it makes sense for,
if someone's able to get to
the minimum efficient scale,
they can take up a lot of the market.
In fact, they could take
up half of the market.
So this type of market might only be able
to really support two
players in this market.
So this is considered to
be a far more concentrated,
concentrated market.
And you could go to a reality
where your minimum efficient
scale is at the market size
or is even larger than the market size.
So let's say that the market
size is not 400 tacos per day,
but let's say we had a market,
let's say we had a market of
195 tacos per day,
per day.
Well, in that world,
whoever can get to 195 tacos
is going to produce most efficiently.
They're not even getting to
the minimum efficient scale.
But the more, the closer that
you can get to that number,
you're going to have the
lowest average total,
long-run average total cost of production,
and so it's going to be very hard
for anyone else to compete with you,
especially if you're taking
up most of the market.
No one else is going to
be able to get to scale,
so they're going to be operating out here
on the long-run average total cost curve.
And so in that world, you
might only have one player.
And when you have one player,
where the market dynamics make it
so that it is actually
efficient for only one player,
this is sometimes referred
to as a natural monopoly.
There's other dynamics that could lead
to a natural monopoly.
But one way to think about it is,
is if you keep getting economies of scale,
up to the market size,
well, then whoever can get
to that market size first
is going to be the most
efficient producer.